[Music]
The Bachelor returns to ABC January
second with Nick Viall the man with a
bachelor nation past only et was on set
for his big photo shoot to find out what
Nick has Easter how would you describe
what your season will be in one word
wild wild why I like honesty like
authenticity and I'm not going to pull
any punches and I'm gonna encourage
women to do the same and I think
subsequently that's gonna make for some
interesting time I want it right now
right now killing it everybody knows
that you slept with Andy and Galen it
happened on TV will you go the distance
and get physical with women before the
fantasy suites as The Bachelor um
probably not yeah that can't work out
very well i think i'm gonna use that
time to you know really get another
women and you know i'm not gonna say you
know still make it steamy you know okay
really like yeah hey I hope it's gonna
be a sexy season but as far as you know
going around all the bases we might pump
the brakes on that a little bit yeah
take it easy I've never really focused
too much about public perception you
know for better or worse i'm going to be
myself and not always edit myself you
know my goal isn't to be mr. popular um
no it's fun to be liked but i'm always
gonna be myself
you